bonjour à toutes et à tous aujourd'hui
je vais faire appel à votre imagination
et à votre amour pour les films
catastrophe vous avez tous en tête les
images de deep inpact armageddon ou des
normes corps célestes qui se collision
entre eux dans une phase apocalyptique
de formation planétaire
et voilà ma question à quoi ressemble la
planète après une telle collision
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au cours de sa formation il a plus de 4
milliards d'années la terre n'a pas eu
la vie facile
elle a subi de nombreuses collisions
avec des corps célestes dont certains
pouvaient avoir la taille de mars
d'ailleurs notre lune est probablement
le résultat d'un tel impact après chaque
collision le mélange des corps célestes
à une planète influence son évolution
sur le long terme
sa composition sa température son orbite
est ce qu'elle va avoir un champ
magnétique champs de lavande
bref tout cela aura donc des
conséquences sur son habitabilité et son
potentiel touristique
des chercheurs de l'institut de
recherche sur les phénomènes hors
équilibre de marseille ont décidé
d'étudier expérimentalement ce qu'il se
passe lorsqu'un planète et himal un bébé
planète rencontre une protoplanète une
planète dans sa phase d'adolescence en
quelque sorte vous dit tu me saoules
retourne dans son en-but il faut
imaginer que ces deux corps célestes
sont déjà différencier c'est à dire
qu'ils ont un noyau riches en fer au
centre et en surface de la roche plus ou
moins solide qui va se liquéfier au
moment où l'impact au moment où l'impact
le planning des images et pulvérisé le
faire de son noyau qui est alors chaud
et sous forme liquide se retrouve mêlée
à l'océan de magma qu'il va traverser
entraînée par la gravité la température
et la composition finale de la planète
vont donc dépendre de l'efficacité des
échanges entre le magma et le faire
pendant cette phase
et c'est justement cette phase de
mélange faire magma que les chercheurs
ont choisi d'étudier expérimentalement
normal quoi de plus simple que de
recréer un impact est un océan de magma
en laboratoire oui vas ramènera pas plus
de six ans de magma là maintenant on
fait la même chose avec celui de 600
milliards de milliards de tonnes à
partie non en réalité les scientifiques
se sont munis d'une cuve de plus d'un
mètre de haut rempli d'un mélange d'eau
et dans produits pour la rendre plus
visqueuse pour modéliser le noyau de fer
liquide qui arrive au moment de l'impact
il utilise du guer l'instant je vous
arrête tout de suite le gars l'instant
n'est pas un pays d'asie centrale
c'est en alliages contenant
principalement du gallium et qui
al'avantage d'être liquide à pression et
température ambiante
enfin pour recréer l'impact il place le
gars l'instant légèrement chauffé dans
un ballon en haut de la cub
et il les clac les chercheurs étudient
alors le comportement de la goutte
initiale du blog de galles instant au
cours de sa descente
filmé à 800 images seconde avec une
caméra ultrarapide ça donne ça vous
voyez ici l'analogue d'un noyau de fer
liquide qui plonge dans un océan de
magma peu wisques jusque récemment cette
phase était uniquement décrite par des
modèles théoriques
certains imaginent un blog qui descend
quasiment sans se fractionner alors que
d'autres prévoient que le fer traverse
l'océan de magma sous forme de pluie
mais ce qu'ont montré les chercheurs par
cette expérience c'est que le
comportement du globe va notamment
dépendre de la différence de viscosité
entre le fer et le magma oui voici trois
expériences filmé à 1000 images par
seconde
on part exactement du même ballon de
guerre instants qui représente le faire
et seuls changent la viscosité du
liquide environnants de gauche à droite
même viscosité que le gars l'instant
cent soixante dix fois plus visqueux et
1600 x plus visqueux donc plus l'océan
de magma et visqueux - le blog se
fragmente durant sa descente
or plus le blog se divise en
gouttelettes plus le mélange sera
efficace et meilleures seront les
échanges de chaleur et d'éléments entre
le fer et le magma
et les chercheurs ont remarqué que la
distance à partir de laquelle le blog se
divise en gouttelettes dépend de sa
taille initiale le bleu se divise après
avoir parcouru une distance d'environ 13
fois son diamètre en début de chute
ainsi cette recherche a permis de tester
la validité de différentes théories sur
la formation des planètes grâce à une
approche expérimentale et puis surtout
ça fait de magnifiques images
[Musique]
oh
voilà donc cette fois pour trouver la
chute c'était plutôt fluide
je viens de me trouver égale instant
[Musique]
n'hésitez pas à aimer partager commenter
et abonnez vous pour ne pas en perdre
une goutte